as we have already discussed we can
estimate an unknown mean of a certain
random variable by generating several
independent samples of that random
variable and taking their average and
this procedure is well justified because
of the weak law of large numbers which
tells us that this estimator converges
when n goes to infinity in probability
to the true mean now we can apply this
idea more generally suppose we want to
estimate the expected value of a
function of a random variable X now G of
X is itself a random variable so if we
have samples of G of X we can use the
same procedure how do we do that we
generate independent samples of X and
these give us independent samples of G
of X we use those independent samples we
average them and by the weak law of
large numbers this quantity as n goes to
infinity will converge in probability to
the expected value of G of X we already
used an idea of this form when we tried
to estimate an unknown variance a
variance is defined as an expectation
and now we can generate samples of X
many independent samples calculate this
quantity and take the average however we
might not know the mean of the
distribution so instead of the true mean
we use an estimated mean which is
estimated the usual way using a sample
average so when n is large this
estimated mean is close to the true mean
so using the estimated mean here will
not make a substantial difference and
then we have essentially independent
samples of this quantity and by
averaging them we obtain an estimate of
the variance which asymptotically as n
goes to infinity will be equal to the
true variance now we can push this idea
even further suppose we wish to estimate
a covariance quite a natural way of
doing the
we can generate independent samples of
the pair of the random variables x and y
so this will be a typical independent
sample and replace the expected value by
a sample average that is we take our
eyes sample our eyes pair and calculate
this quantity which looks very much like
the quantity in here except that we're
using the estimated means in place of
the true means we obtain these
quantities and average and of them again
using the weak law of large numbers one
can argue that this estimate will
converge to the true value of the
covariance as n goes to infinity and
once we have estimates of a covariance
and of variance then we can use that to
estimate correlation coefficients look
at this formula which is the definition
of the correlation coefficient if we
just replace all quantities involved
here by corresponding estimates this
gives us an estimate of the correlation
coefficient all of these ways of forming
estimates can be shown we are omitting
the details of the argument but
hopefully you get the idea by now all of
these quantities are consistent
estimators that is when the sample size
goes to infinity they approach the
correct values of what we're trying to
estimate so this is just an opening of
what else a statistician might be
interested in and if you are wondering
what's the further agenda after this
point it would be something like the
following
typically a statistician might want to
say as much as possible about the
probability distribution of an estimator
for example we have here an estimate of
the covariance this estimate is going to
be a random variable because it is
determined by random quantities what is
the probability distribution of this
quantity can we describe it
approximately what is the mean squared
error associated with this estimator and
if you wish to construct confidence
intervals how would you do it these are
all topics that statisticians have
studied in
and you could see more about these
topics if you were to take a further
class on statistics and inference but we
will not go any deeper in this course